the entity that is scp-4840-a
is an old man who calls himself the
caretaker of the floating city of
atadapadopoulos
he holds secrets that will change the
foundation's understanding of the world
forever the old man was initially
encountered by captain francis pike who
first explored autodapadopolis for the
foundation it was here that
scp-4840-a provided some insight into
the city and its mysteries over a decade
later the foundation has sent dr val
osterovic to interview the old man
unbeknownst to her everything she and
everyone else thinks they know is about
to change
scp-4840-a walks into the room where dr
osterovich sits please take a seat she
says to the old man he looks around at
the barren stone walls and takes a few
steps into the center of the room dr
osterovich motions to the chair across
the table from her the old man pulls the
chair out and takes a seat dr osterovich
leans over and pushes a button on the
voice recorder resting on the table
that's very impressive the old man says
examining the device so it records
everything i say that is correct
response dr osterovich the old man looks
around the room and then directly into
her eyes a smile cracks his lips i
wondered when the foundation would want
to talk like actually talk you are a
seeker of knowledge you reminded me a
little of my brother he may have been
the greatest scholar that ever lived and
now you seek the truth for that we will
need to take a journey billions of years
into the past billions asked dr
osterovich billions the old man answers
folding his hands onto the table i was
there from the beginning the old man
begins to tell his tale it is so vividly
worded that dr osterovic feels like she
is living in the story like she's been
transported to a different time and
place to experience the creation of the
universe and the fall of man in the
beginning there was light the iron god
manifested itself his sword cut flaming
stars into the sky the god of flesh
sprinkled drops of blood onto the earth
creating the first life the serpent of
sin and its stark brother laid the
foundation for what is and what is not a
young boy looked up at the sky as the
earth began to turn he watched the
creation of everything from the great
hall of odadapadopoulos
this was where humans were born wait i
don't understand says dr osterovich are
you telling me that otodopadopoulos is
like the garden of eden i am not telling
you that it is like anything the old man
says with a wink but i think you want to
learn more about a different tale
something i will get to in time in the
early days of the universe there were
only a few humans in existence for
millions of years they watched through
the haze of creation to learn more about
the reality they were born into they
built the very first city and upon
completion it became the spot where that
which is came to be
there were only ever two true gods is
and is not they were the only truths in
the entire universe is brought the
serpent into the world it searched for
once it came and to learn about all the
truths that had been hidden from it the
is not was the darker shadow of is it
controlled everything that stretched out
beyond the world and into the unknown
the two gods could not exist without one
another when you refer to the serpent do
you mean the entity that resides in the
wanderers library interjects dr
osterovic one and the shame replies the
old man it was during the time after the
is and is not finished creation but the
monsters and demons inhabited the earth
however there was order the monsters of
other worlds were kept separate these
entities would be in the dreams of men
but were never able to cross over to
their world it was the strange folk to
the west of anadapadopoulos that first
opened their eyes to the cosmos they
were created from the last remnants of
the is but were not human they were
something that could not be explained by
logic the humans were looked after by
the mothers of the newly created world
the wolf the bear the sow and the lion
were their protectors as the days went
on and more men and women walked the
streets of adolpadopolis they met in the
great hall of the city where they would
seek counsel and listen to the first
king of men his name was asim which came
from the word that meant is his skin
looked as if it were made of gold and he
had power beyond imagining although asem
was only a man he could create mountains
with his hands and deep oceans with his
feet he had a lance that could kill even
the gods assem was a great leader but
deep inside of him grew the first vice
of men
envy he would look to the heavens and
desired them to be his humans had built
the greatest city that would ever be and
yet the king wanted more so he took it
as sam was the first being to see
something from a world that was not his
own he stole a crown and when he
gathered the inhabitants of
odadapadopoulos to the great hall to
show them his new relic he declared
himself the king of all that is he built
a seat of power on top of the spot where
mankind first found is as sam was still
kind to the people of adapadopoulos but
he always desired more then the great
betrayals came asem's sons grew up in
the shadow of their father's envy the
first betrayal was by his middle son who
coveted his father's crown he demanded
that it be passed on to him and when sm
refused the son amassed an army and laid
siege to the world but the middle son
was struck down by his father and locked
in a stone tomb deep under the grounds
of otadapadopoulos
the second betrayal came from sam's
oldest son he went behind his father's
back and spoke passionately to the
people using sense and reason to demand
that they make his father give him the
crown
the people of earth worshiped assem's
oldest son as if he were a god seeing
this assem removed the poison that his
eldest son had put into their minds he
then dealt with him by casting his son
to the most desolate place on earth
where he would wander until the sun went
down in the east the most devastating
betrayal of all came from the youngest
son of essium he came into his father's
bedroom while he slept and took the
crown from his head the youngest son and
his followers ran away with the crown
when a sem awoke his heart broke with
what his youngest son whom he loved more
than anyone or anything in the entire
world had done an endless rage welled up
in the king and he turned the earth into
a smoking wasteland a sem searched
tirelessly for his youngest offspring
and the crown his envy knew no bounds
and he desired nothing more than for his
crown to be returned to him for
thousands of years assam searched but
could not find what he was looking for
the crown had been hidden away and
slowly faded into legend the world
gradually returned to normal fields
began to regrow and forest sprouted from
the smoldering embers of the planet's
wide siege that assem had carried out in
search of his crown the followers of his
youngest son spread across the region
which would later become known as europe
then came the time of endless wars men
fought demons and monsters men fought
one another from these wars came the
deaths of many and the ancient ruins
that have long since been consumed by
the sands of the earth but these wars
would lead to the current age of human
history during the great wars one man
hid and watched from the great hall at
adidapadopoulos he witnessed the world
consume itself but the worst was yet to
come
zorus the sky king found his way to
atadapadopoulos and demanded that he be
given the lance of sem however the lance
had been lost long ago with the fall of
the first king of man as he ravaged the
planet looking for his crown zorus
refused to believe that the lance was
not in the city and began to destroy
adidapadopoulos as he looked for it but
before zorus could completely demolish
everything a hidden mystery was called
upon to stop the threat the last of the
titans the great dragon bachrath who
slumbered beneath the city emerged from
the earth and carried odadapadopoulos
into the sky forever separating it from
the men of the world you mean until the
foundation discovered it says dr
osterovich well
yes and no replies the old man that was
one before you the history of man
progressed deva hero of gilgamesh killed
saras ii's only son in single combat on
the fields of jerusalem the dreaded
sorcerer noah el menthoff flooded the
lands until he was killed by maladthro
the wrathful jurai apollyon sailed
across the great sea to meet with the
king of the night children but was
buried alive to feed the heart of their
tree goddess then from the east came
lancelot like the night from king
arthur's knights of the round table as
dr osterovich the old man frowns oh that
was a different lancelot the one who
came to the floating city was called the
demon lancelot as the demon lancelot
approached adapadopoulos any remaining
allies who still walked the earth were
called upon for assistance the evil army
that the demon commanded would not be
easily defeated lancelot first targeted
bathrata the old dragon who had lifted
adadapadopoulos into the skies next he
battled the sea lord arcturius he made
quick work of the hero beowulf and
lastly fell the king of david all that
remained between the demon lancelot and
the city of adodus was one human he took
up his sword and battled the demon but
lancelot was too strong the demon used
the flails attached to his six arms to
demolish anything in his path he was
about to land the deadly blow when with
its last breath the dragon bathrata
ripped the demon lancelot's heart out of
his chest and cast him into the temple
of sunset where his dead body lies to
this day all was now quiet in
autodopadopolous the gods and heroes of
old had been lost or were hidden away
the search for the crown continued on
and even asam himself is somewhere
scouring the earth for his precious
relic the floating city of
was forgotten so
basically most of the scps that the
foundation contains comes straight from
your history dr osterovic says yes i
believe you are correct replies the old
man just from this story alone there
must be entities you recognize and the
fact that many of the gods early men and
demons are immortal means you will
probably hear more about them in time
the demon lancelot may seem dead but his
body still radiates heat i feel it is
only a matter of time until we must do
battle once again okay there is
something i don't understand dr
osterovic says the old man nods at her
where do you fit into this story i
understand you were there at creation
but you know so much and i can't help
but feel you are leaving something out
the old man pauses he lets out a long
sigh my name is seth the old man says
brother to cain and abel son of adam
ellison the first king of men i was the
king's youngest who stole the crown i
was the one who looked at the night sky
and asked my father for a star all my
own he pulled one out of the heavens for
me and it became the iron crown it drove
my father to madness my brothers to
butchery and led to the ruination of our
kingdom the crown is the seed at the
root of all evil seth stares blankly
across the room and it was meant as a
gift for me now watch scp-073-076
kane vs abel as cp animation or check
out scp-343
god scp animation